let's continue thinking about how
rational agents make decisions
so here we're told that sally runs a
business that only sells hamburgers in a
building she owns
every month they sell 5 000 hamburgers
at five dollars per hamburger she spends
two dollars per hamburger on supplies
bread meat lettuce etc
she also pays mike and raj each twenty
five hundred dollars per month to work
at the restaurant finally the utilities
cost 500 per month
sally works full-time at the restaurant
and keeps the accounting profits for
herself
what is the accounting profit of the
business so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
all right now let's think about this
together we're going to think about it
in terms of some of the types of costs
we've thought about in the past
so when we think about benefits and here
we can think about it to a firm although
it's fully owned by sally the benefit to
his firm of doing business is its
revenue
so the total revenue that she collects
and everything we're going to be doing
is is going to be per month
so her total revenue is going to be her
price times quantity so it's going to be
5 000 hamburgers at five dollars per
hamburger so that is going to be 25 000
once again all of this is going to be
per month so once again we can view this
as the total benefit that the firm that
her business is getting and now let's
think about the costs so first we can
think about the cost of her supplies
it's oftentimes referred to costs of
goods sold but i'll just write supplies
here so costs
costs colon so let's put supplies
supplies
that would be five thousand hamburgers
times two dollars per hamburger so
that's a ten thousand dollar cost
ten thousand dollars then she has the
cost of her employees
so employees i'll just write it i'll
abbreviate it like that
what's that going to be well she has two
folks at twenty five hundred dollars per
month each so that's going to be five
thousand dollars two times twenty five
hundred dollars five thousand dollars
and then last but not least she has her
utilities
so utilities
let's do util for short that's going to
be 500
per month
and so from this we can calculate the
accounting profit
so we get the accounting profit
accounting
profit
is going to be
25 000 minus 15
500 that's going to be 9
per month
and she gets to keep all of this and so
this seems like a pretty good amount of
money to be earning she's earning six
figures a year
but the question is is it rational for
her to do this
well some of you might be correctly
thinking well in order to determine
whether it's rational for her to
continue running this business we have
to know what the implicit costs are here
we've only just looked at the explicit
costs and the most important of the
implicit costs is the opportunity cost
and to factor that we have to know well
maybe what she could have rented her
building out if she wasn't running this
burger business and maybe what she could
do with her time if she wasn't working
at the business full-time so we need a
little bit more information and let's
see if we can get that
so now we are told that sally could rent
out her building for five thousand
dollars per month she can also make six
thousand dollars per month as an
accountant
based on this what is the economic
profit of her business so pause this
video and see if you can figure this out
well one way to think about it is we can
start with our counting profit and then
subtract out all the implicit costs
especially these opportunity costs right
over here so her opportunity cost
opportunity
costs are going to be
per month well if she doesn't run this
business she could rent out her building
for five thousand dollars per month
and that if she wasn't doing this full
time she could make six thousand dollars
per month as an accountant
six thousand dollars right over there
and so her opportunity costs are a total
of
eleven thousand dollars
and so now her economic profit would be
her total benefit
minus her explicit costs
minus her implicit costs her economic
profit economic
profit
is going to be well we could start the 9
500 and subtract the 11 000
it is negative
500 dollars it's important to realize
because economic profit always factors
in the explicit costs and then other
potential implicit costs
economic profit will never be higher
than a counting profit and assuming
there are some implicit costs it will
always be lower than accounting profit
so now based on all of what we've
explored is it rational for sally to
continue running her burger business
well based on the information we've been
given it doesn't seem rational for her
to continue running her burger business
she makes 9 500 in a accounting profit
from the business but she's incurring 11
000 of opportunity cost to do so and
that's what makes her economic profit
negative this is not rational now if we
had more information maybe she hates
being an accountant maybe there's an a
benefit for her working at the burger
business she has more flexibility with
her time she likes being self-employed
she doesn't have to listen to her
manager tell her what to do if that were
the case then it would change the
calculations some because there would be
an extra benefit from her running her
burger joint but we don't know and based
on the information we have it doesn't
seem rational for her to continue